قال الحديث اكثر حول هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو محرره شؤون الدوليه سمير خالد
الغرابلي اهلا بك خالد ابدا معك بهدف هذا
المؤتمر
المعلن من هذا المؤتمر ان فرنسا تريد ان
تساعد اوكرانيا على ان يمر الشتاء بخير
يعني تقديم المساعدات حشد المجتمع الدولي
لتقديم المساعدات ليس لتقديم المساعدات
غدا او بعد غد لكن الان لاننا في فصل
الشتاء والاوكرانيون يعانون بشده لان
الروس يقصفون مصادر الطاقه يقصفون البنيه
التحتيه وهناك معانا حقيقيه داخل اوكرانيا
ومن هنا فرنسا تريد من المجتمع الدوله ان
يساعد الاوكرانيين الان وبسرعه عاجله ومن
هنا استطاعت ان تجمع وعود نحن لا نتحدث
عمال وصل بالفعل الاوكرانيين ولكن عن وعود
نحو مليار دولار او اكثر قليلا ونصيب
فرنسا نحو 76 همم مليار
وجزء من هذه المساعده هو نوع من تنسيق
تقديم المساعدات بمعنى
سيكون هناك منصه الاوكرانيون يجددون دائما
احتياجاتهم وعلى الدول المانحه من تريد ان
تساعد ترى هذه الاحتياجات ومن يريد ان
يساعد يتقدم ليقدم ما يمكن ان يقدمه من
مساعدات هذا هو المعلم لكن الذي يكاد يكون
غير معلن هذا الاجتماع الاخر الذي نظم بين
نحو 500 شركه فرنسيه والمسؤولين
الاوكرانيين لبحث اعاده الاعمار اعاده
الاعمار بالعاده ولا تكون بعد انتهاء
الحرب لكن الان نتحدث عنها مع استمرار على
الحرب ومع استمرار قصف البنيه همم التحتيه
الاوكرانيه السؤال يبقى لماذا لماذا لان
من مصلحه فرنسا تتحرك الان
الفرنسيون يعلمون الان هناك مدن انسحب
منها الروس يعيش فيها الملايين البنيه
التحتيه في هذه المدن دمرت وتحتاج لاعاده
بناءها لكي يستطيع هؤلاء ان يعيشوا وهذه
فرصه مناسبه جدا للشركات الفرنسيه اللي
تضع قدمها في هذه المنطقه في اوكرانيا
لانها تعلم من هناك منافسه شديده جدا
وستكون اكثر ضراوه مع انتهاء الحرب
وبالتالي هي فرصه اولا للتجني الارباح من
خلال مشاريع يمكن ان تتم الان والحكومه
الفرنسيه تعرض بعض الضمانات على الشركات
التي تريد ان تستثمر والثانيا همم تثبيت
القدم في خلال الوضع الحالي حتى اثناء
الحرب سيساعد فرنسا ويسهل الامور اكثر
لفرنسا لاحقا عندما تنتهي الحرب وتبدا
عمليه اعاده الاعمار الفعليه يكون اكرهنون
عرفوا الشركات الفرنسيه واصبح لها مكان
وتحاول ان تفرض نفسها بكلمات اخرى
الفرنسيون في الصباح يجمعون المال
لاوكرانيا وهذا لانهم يريدون ان تكون
اوكرانيا اكثر قدره على الصمود لكن ايضا
لان لهم مصلحه لشركاتهم عمليه جمع الاموال
ربما تسهل دخول السوق الاوكرانيه اكثر ومن
خلال مساعدات العسكريه التي تقدم ايضا
وارسال الشركات الفرنسيه الان يثبت
اقدامها ليسهل عمليه يسهل عمليه المشاركه
بحصه اكبر قدر المستطاع في عمليه اعاده
الاعمار
مشاركه في اعاده الاعمار هذا ما تريد
فرنسا همم ما هي فرصها فعليه همم على مدى
سنوات القادمه
النصيب الاكبر سيكون للولايات المتحده
قطعا اعاده اعمار دوله بعد الحرب بمثابه
في الحرب الدول التي ساهمت في الحرب كلما
زادت مساهمات تزيد حصاتها في هذه الكعكه
ال- ال- على راس القائمه الولايات المتحده
قدمت اكثر من 19 مليار دولار للاوكراني في
هذه الحرب وقراتها بالفرنسيه نحو ثلاثه
مليارات فقط وبالتالي الولايات المتحده
عندما
تنتهي هذه الحرب
صحيحا هذه ليست جمعيات خيريه هذه الدول
تبحث عن مصالح من مصلحه الولايات المتحده
في روسيا في هذه الحرب من مصلحه الولايات
المتحده بيع غزه الى الاوروبيين الحلفاء
باسعار مرتفعه جدا لكن مصلحتها ايضا ان
تجني ثم ما خلال هذه الحرب وان تكون نصيبي
يكون نصيب الاسد لشركاتها في اعاده
الاعمار وبالتالي هذا سيفر هذه هي القاعده
التي في في الواقع العملي ما بين الدول
وقد تفرضها الولايات المتحده هذا اول
ثانيا الولايات المتحده قادره على ان تفرض
وضعها بشكل بس لسبب اخر لان الولايات
المتحده بالاساس كانت هي اكثر الدول كرما
مع اوكرانيا في تقديم المساعدات
وبالتالي عندما نسال من الذي سيدفع اعاده
الاعمار اعاده الاعمار تكون مساعدات قروض
وبالتالي في عمليه اعاده اعمارنا ممكن
الولايات المتحده ان استمرت بنفس النقل
تكون اكثر كارما وبالتالي يعني قدمت قروض
ومساعدات ومساعدات تجني بها مكاسب سياسيه
هي لا ترمي المال في الهواء
ستفرض ان يكون تكون شركات خاصه الاسد وان
لم تكن هي التي لا حصه الاسد في تقديم
المساعدات والهبات والقروض سيلجاون الى
الاموال الروسيه المجمده نحو ثلاثمائه من
اعمار روس من اموال الروس مجمده حاليا لكن
لكي يتم استخدام هذا المال لابد ان تكون
هناك جهه قويه تبادر وتكون على استعداد
لمواجهه روسيا لاستغلال هذا المال وفي
الغالب الولايات المتحده هي التي قادر على
فعل ذلك كل ذلك ضعف موضع قوه نهيك ايضا عن
صاحب او رئيس البلد رئيس الاوكراني
زيريسكي بالاساس هو مقتنع ان من يوفر له
الحمايه هم الامريكيين وبالتالي اعاده
اعمار يعني ربط مستقبله بالامريكيين
والشركات الامريكيه هذا يوفر له النوع من
الحمايه حتى وان لم نتحدث عن انضمام لحلف
الاطلسي هل هذا معناه ان لن يكون لفرنسا
موقع سيكون لها بحكم الجغرافيا اولا بحكم
ان هي قدمت مساعدات لابد ان يكون لها نصيب
ثانيا بحكم الجغرافيا اوكرانيا الجغرافيه
في اوروبا وسيحتاج الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومن هنا عمليه اعاده الاعمار
ينظر اليها من قبل الاوكرانيين على نوع من
اعداد اوكرانيا للانضمام الى الاتحاد
اوروبيه ايضا تحديث اوكرانيا لن يكون همم
اعاده همم بناء على الوضع القديم انما
اعاده بناء دوله حديثه على طريق ضمها الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى طريق ضمها
لاتفاقيات لحد الاتحاد الاوروبيه التي
تضمن نوع من الدفاع العسكري ايضا وبالتالي
له مصلحه ان يكون لفرنسا حصه لكن حصه يتم
التفاوض عليها مع الفرنسيين حتى وان كان
هناك توتر مع الفرنسي وحتى ربما بين
الامريكيين والفرنسيين السميل خالد
الغرابلي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الاضاءه
شكرا لك